battlefield is easily one of the most
recognizable franchises in the video
game industry known for grand spectacle
and chaotic multiplayer focused moments
the battlefield games have come a long
way from the original release almost 20
years ago we have a lot to break down
today from battlefield 1942 all the way
to dice's latest anticipated release
battlefield 2042 before we get started
though drop a like sub and do all that
usual stuff if you're interested in
being in the loop whenever battlefield
videos drop we're gonna have a lot of
them coming your way so let's dive into
the history of battlefield beginning
with the game that started it all
battlefield 1942 was the first
battlefield game ever and looking back
at some of the gameplay footage it just
gets me feeling all nostalgic inside it
was originally pitched as a gamecube
exclusive believe it or not but
considering that nintendo had no online
strategy at the time the platform of
choice eventually became pc battlefield
1942 was developed on the refractor
engine since frostbite wasn't really a
thing yet it had a single player mode
against ai bots and multiplayer online
or on a local network so for all you
youngins out there this meant that if
you wanted to play with your friends you
had to lug all of your pc [ __ ] to their
house battlefield 1942 had special
infantry classes which would become a
long lasting staple of the series
infantry scouts assault anti-tank medic
and engineer the later games would
redefine and simplify the roles but in
battlefield 1942 each class had its own
tactical advantage for example scouts
had long-range weapons and could spot
enemies but they suffered in close
quarter combat vehicular combat was also
a big point of focus in battlefield 1942
and there was a wide range of them
aircraft bombers ships submarines
aircraft carriers turrets tanks jeeps
the list goes on and on the maps were
based on world war ii and included
locations from the pacific european
north african eastern and italian fronts
the main forces were the axis powers
against the allies and the game put
emphasis on multiplayer compared to the
countless other world war fps shooters
released around that era such as the
call of duty and medal of honor series
battlefield 1942 had control point
focused gameplay capturing points
allowed teams to gain forward momentum
through the use of spawns when a flag
was captured players could access
vehicles that would then spawn near
those points giving a combined arm's
advantage these tactics were often used
in conquest the default battlefield game
mode where in the case of battlefield
1942 a team would be unable to respawn
once all the control points were lost
battlefield 1942 set a fantastic
framework for future battlefield games
to build off of where online multiplayer
is the main focus with high octane
combat and sandbox moments compounding
together resulting in a lot of fun chaos
and fast action it had dlc in 2003 what
battlefield 1942 road to rome and
battlefield 1942 secret weapons of world
war ii road to rome introduced very
minor class changes like bayonets for
engineers rifles as well as additional
maps focusing on battles taking place in
italy secret weapons of world war ii had
a few more features like a new gameplay
mode and new factions like the sas
commandos there was even a jet pack now
this set the trend for battlefield dlc
to include basically newer updated maps
weapons and vehicles but not much else
although there are some notable
exceptions which we'll be sure to
mention later on
battlefield vietnam in 2004 was an
official sequel to 1942 and featured
asymmetrical warfare in its gameplay
which is kind of neat the us and north
vietnamese were the two obvious factions
in battlefield vietnam and were given
wildly different kits and vehicles the
us forces relied on mechanized warfare
while the vietnamese relied on infantry
tactics so you'll find things like heavy
tanks and helicopters and bombers for
the us while the vietnamese were given
opportunities to counter equipped with
things like anti-tank and anti-aircraft
weapons the intention was to accurately
depict the historical conditions of war
cool attention to detail was given to
the gameplay with the vietnamese having
a cipy hole basically a mobile spawn
point that represented the vast tunnel
networks the vietnamese actually used
during the war there were also
improvised weapons and tactics used such
as punji stick traps some cool quality
of life adjustments were introduced like
allowing players to swap vehicle
soundtracks with their own music and
battlefield vietnam introduced passenger
gunners a gameplay mechanic that would
carry on to future battlefield titles
battlefield 2 was a big leap forward for
the franchise introducing changes that
emphasized teamwork and collaboration
there were plenty of improved physics
dynamic lighting and a rudimentary
introduction to destruction one of the
most important traits that would develop
into defining many modern battlefield
games the reason all of this was
possible was thanks to the upgraded
refractor 2 engine the story in
battlefield 2 involved a world war
fought by the us eu and uk against
russia china and the fictional mec
beyond that there wasn't much else on a
plot level the game's single player mode
included three difficulty settings and
both single player and multiplayer use
the same maps if you decided to go solo
the single player mode had 16 player
battlefields against bots and if you had
the privilege of playing online the
internet multiplayer modes offered up to
64 players now that became a common
player account in later games but it was
super groundbreaking at the time players
weren't restricted to choosing a single
class since they could swap on the field
by picking up any kits from dead
soldiers and player classes remained
largely unchanged except for a special
forces class and the introduction of the
support class battlefield 2 only had one
exclusively water-based vehicle the
rigid inflatable boat however certain
vehicles were multi-terrain and they
could travel in water squads included up
to six soldiers and teams could be up to
nine squads with an integrated voice
over ip system letting squad members
chat with each other if you were a
leader of a squad you could assign
objectives in the game like attacking an
area squad leaders could also issue
requests for assets from a team
commander and it was one of the most
significant additions to battlefield 2.
the commander was a new position that
could only be filled by one player on
each team anyone could apply for the
spot but the game would give priority to
those of higher rank as a commander you
had access to the commander screen which
was kind of like its own rts game the
screen gave the commander an overview of
the battlefield as a whole or they could
zoom in and see the map in real time
commanders had access to artillery
strikes vehicles supply drops and uavs
and they could all be deployed to assist
the team they could also resign at any
point freeing the spot up or kind of
hilariously in my mind they could
actually be forcibly removed by a
straight up mutiny vote from the team
the game had an expansion and quote
booster packs which were smaller deal
seen battlefield 2 special forces
brought the usual additions of weapons
vehicles and maps but added infantry
equipment like zip lines and grappling
hooks which did significantly alter the
gameplay the booster packs consisted of
euro force and armored fury and brought
less notable additions there were
in-game rewards in battlefield 2 in the
form of unlockable weapons ribbons
badges medals all acknowledging your
gameplay accomplishments battlefield 2
also had an in-game recorder for replay
files could be downloaded from a server
that supported the recorder and each
recording would be played in the
battlefield 2 engine sizing up between 1
to 8 megabytes which man i wish we could
go back to those file sizes huh
battlefield 2 modern combat is briefly
going to be mentioned here but it's
worth bringing up this game because it
was the first battlefield game to hit
consoles across multiple generations
originally releasing on the ps2 and xbox
with an updated version coming to xbox
360 about a year later the story was
also kind of sinister he had nato and
china duking it out in kazakhstan with a
fictional terrorist organization known
as the burning flag just straight up
committing war crimes like left and
right and they were tricking the two
factions into believing that their
opponent did it i that's just kind of
messed up if you ask me but moving on
this one might hit home for some of the
ogs in the comments the fourth mainland
game in the series battlefield 2142 came
out in 2006 and was set during a new ice
age depicted as quote the new cold war
of the 22nd century it's basically
global warming now at this time you have
the european union and the pan-asian
coalition fighting over what little
unfrozen land is left similar to
battlefield 2 you had 64 player servers
for online play with the 16 player solo
mode against bots and stop me if you've
heard this before but you had conquest
as the main game mode with infantry
classes such as the assault engineer
support and recon class despite
battlefield 2142 being a sequel so much
of the core gameplay loop remained the
same which goes to show how dice really
struck gold here a genuinely novel
gameplay mode that separated 2142 from
its predecessors however is the titan
gameplay mode not to confuse any younger
gamers out there that think of this when
they hear the word titan but the titan
mode in 2142 involve teams each having
one titan and trying to destroy the
opposing titan while defending their own
the titans were massive heavily armored
flying warships with force fields to
protect themselves from infiltration or
general weapon fire while these force
fields were up players would fight for
control of anti-titan missile silos
scattered across the battlefield on the
ground the titans were movable but only
by each team's commander and this
honestly foreshadowed some future
battlefield 4 issues but commanders were
usually hesitant to move their titans
and some servers even outright disabled
the ability and let me tell you why the
reason behind this was because when the
titans moved it would cause the servers
to be so unstable as a result of
dramatic latency issues that it would
cause players to crash or be removed
from the game now the titans defend
themselves and contribute to the fight
on the ground with four anti-ground guns
and two anti-aircraft guns if players
were able to bust the titans force field
shields there were two ways to destroy
the enemy titan at that point one is to
just use the anti-titan missiles which
is boring the other is to board the
titan using assault pods launch from an
apc air transport or even another titan
and then once players landed inside that
titan they would have to destroy four
reactor consoles to gain access to the
main reactor room and then finally you
would blow up the reactor and you would
have 30 seconds to escape before the
titan explodes so you tell me which one
sounds cooler now i personally never
played battlefield 2142 despite actually
owning a lot of the og collection but
this sounds awesome as hell and i
clearly missed out no doubt the
destruction of titans must have been a
point of inspiration for dice when they
eventually incorporated levolution in
battlefield 4 and behemoths and
battlefield 1.
battlefield bat company was developed
for ps3 and xbox 360 in 2008 and a
dramatic shift from previous battlefield
games the story campaign took center
stage this time around in the campaign
you controlled private preston marlow
and followed his exploits as his squad
attempted to steal gold from mercenaries
in the middle of a war between the us
and russia the campaign was incredibly
humorous with a lot of witty banter and
tongue-in-cheek moments thanks to the
surprisingly varied cast of characters
that helped bring the narrative to light
like the nervous sweetwater and the
pyromaniac gordon haggard jr oh yeah
we could get one of those monster trucks
like
truckasaurus rex i bet that surprised
the hell out of those russians the game
was also such a mood like just listen to
the menu music for a second
[Music]
classic now we've also ditched the days
of the refractor engine and are now
entering the first years of frostbite
the destruction capabilities of
frostbite 1.0 weren't advanced yet but
you weren't confined to things like
blowing up bridges only in battlefield 2
and bad company you could use explosives
to blow some holes in house walls and
you had access to different types of
utility and equipment for instance you
could regain health by jabbing yourself
with a needle that was on a cool down
timer or you could repair any vehicle
with an engineer style tool with such a
dramatic shift in prioritizing the
campaign the multiplayer didn't quite
reach the grand scale of prior games but
it was still fine honestly like what
matters is that the game excelled with
its goal of being designed for consoles
first the multiplayer modes in bat
company were small with support for only
up to 24 players and despite a good
variety of vehicles like attack
helicopters there were no longer any
fighter jets or bomber
planes battlefield 1943 was distributed
digitally for xbox 360 and ps3 consoles
although it was a little bit of like a
half step of a battlefield for me you
can call it something more of like a
beautiful battlefield snack it had a
super addictive and very focused loop
with constant rewards popping up on
screen so it was really solid for what
it was there were some post-launch
updates like granting access to the air
superiority mode and the coral scene map
after all players collectively reached
43 million kills the game was really
limited though and had only three
classes infantrymen rifleman and scout
there was a regenerating health system
and the only multiplayer mode was the
series signature conquest mode each map
also had an airfield where if captured a
third plane could be utilized for a
potential advantage battlefield 1943
used frostbite 1.5 which meant that some
structures could now be fully destroyed
as well
alright i know you guys have been
waiting for this one because now we are
cooking with gas we have reached
arguably the best battlefield game of
all time trust me i am not speaking from
personal experience since i haven't had
the privilege of playing bad company 2
as much plus i'm a little partial
towards battlefield 4 and 1 just because
i grew up with those games but instead a
huge number of you guys watching my
battlefield videos have been super vocal
sharing your experience with bad company
2 and it is undeniable that this game is
clearly one of the top battlefield games
ever released with only the original
battlefield 2 pulling equal enthusiasm
from series veterans picking up where
battlefield bad company left off in the
campaign you regain control of preston
marlowe with slick war film style
cutscenes and an indiana jones worthy
plot you could just sit there for hours
listening to the squad banter there were
new vehicle additions like the quad bike
a personal watercraft the sikorsky uh-60
black hawk and a north rip grumman mq8
fire scout that can be controlled from
remote computer terminals to be fair
battlefield hadn't fully figured out the
air ground balance just yet and in
multiplayer gamers quickly figured out
that you could like jeep stuff the scout
to win in slightly cheap manners what
really stood out about bad company 2
multiplayer was the absolute bonkers
destruction maps would start pristine
and end up mostly leveled by the time
they were done rush crates would
sometimes be in buildings that players
could either capture or just completely
level to the ground there was so much
going on each round with dirt flying
structures exploding and that oh so
satisfying mechanic of getting your ears
rocked by tank fire rush maps were also
very focused and meandering they would
typically take players through a journey
from one side of the map to the other
bad company 2 vietnam was a dlc that had
5 new maps 6 vehicles and 15 weapons
with the fifth map operation hastings
originally set to be unlocked when the
community reached 69 million team play
actions such as revives resupplies and
assists on each platform the game also
added a pve co-op mode called onslaught
later on
battlefield 3 came out of the gate
firing with a visually souped-up
frostbite 2.0 engine and was released on
pc ps3 and xbox 360. the seventh main
installment in the battlefield franchise
battlefield 3 was a direct sequel to
battlefield 2 and his campaign followed
two different characters henry blackburn
and dmitry mayakovsky battlefield 3
reintroduced a lot of elements that were
absent from the bad company games such
as a variety of aircraft the ability to
go prone and 64 player battles which
seemed like a console restraint as only
pc players could really access those
massive lobbies in battlefield 3. the
ground areas on xbox 360 and the ps3
versions were also limited to help
accommodate the lower player count
making for a lot of close quarter
boundaries the maps themselves were set
in real world locations like paris
tehran new york city oman and had a wide
variety of urban streets metro downtown
areas and open landscapes suited to
vehicle combat the battlelog which was a
free cross-platform social service with
the built-in text message voice comms
and game stats allowed players to even
join games of friends that were already
playing mid-match so long as you both
were on the same platform i'm not gonna
lie though especially on pc i wasn't the
biggest fan and i've only had to deal
with the system recently having to
launch games from an internet browser
that constantly had updates and often
crashed didn't really seem like the best
idea either way with frostbite 2.0 came
destruction 3.0 and more extensive
weapon attachments which meant that
certain weapon mechanics were reworked
to take advantage of the new engine
rocket launchers could disable vehicles
now before completely destroying them
bipod attachments became a thing that
could be deployed while prone or near
appropriate structures like ledges
providing huge boosts to recoil control
and accuracy falling debris was now
potentially lethal to the player and
suppressing fire was added which wasn't
really my favorite thing to be honest
because with suppressive fire the player
vision would get super blurred and take
a penalty to health regeneration and
accuracy which is good for realism bad
for having fun thankfully it was later
toned down though you also had micro
destruction where some smaller primary
guns could shoot through some things
like wooden walls or even glass windows
battlefield 3 dlc was plentiful like
back to carkin close quarters armored
kill aftermath and end game they also
included things like unique dog tags
remade throwback maps from battlefield 2
and these were all neat additional bites
of content added on to battlefield 3.
the game also had a lot of easter eggs
referencing other ea games like mirror's
edge and even mass effect
battlefield 4 is one of my personal
favorites and is the battlefield game i
spent all my time in college with i love
this game so much i made an entire video
about it on this very channel and it
turns out i wasn't the only one that
likes the game contrary to many critics
i actually really also enjoyed the
campaign which had several mini sandbox
style levels your character wrecker
could have teammates engage enemies at
your command and you could mark enemies
with tactical binoculars the set pieces
were pretty wicked and the campaign was
a fun sideshow to the main attraction
the multiplayer battlefield 4 brought 64
player matches to all current gen
platforms at the time like the new xbox
one and ps4 with older gen consoles like
the 360 and ps3 being relegated to 24
player matches players could use the
spectator mode to watch through first or
third person cameras or a free roam
camera to pan around the map from any
angle sadly the replay mode did not
return from battlefield 2. the most
significant change to battlefield 4's
gameplay without a doubt was levolution
we've got another video entirely
dedicated to breaking down all the
different types of evolution in
battlefield 4 and why they're so great
but to briefly explain here levolutions
were pinnacle battlefield moments where
the map would change sometimes in
dramatic fashion in real time based on
the player's actions because most
revolutions had a trigger maybe you
started a detonation countdown or maybe
you blew up the supporting base of a
hotel resort causing it to topple
spectacularly the majority of the game
otherwise was very similar to
battlefield 3 but they reduced the
annoying suppression blur for the most
part as far as i could tell and expanded
the weapon attachment system weapon kits
were slightly tuned as well with
carbines being available to all classes
but pdw is being exclusive to engineers
recom kits were more mobile and could
zero in on sites by setting aiming
distance with more optics and
accessories than previous games the game
unfortunately though had a huge number
of technical issues upon release so much
so it became a point of genuine
controversy with even lawsuits being
filed players were being booted out of
servers left and right and it was
extremely difficult to complete a game
from start to finish ironically the
coolest part of battlefield 4 also ended
up being its achilles heel from a
stability standpoint and the network
issues were kind of similar to one of
their older games remember the titans
from battlefield 2142 yeah because
anytime evolution occurred players in
the server all held their collective
breath hoping they wouldn't get booted
from the sheer amount of data that the
server was processing as the levolution
played out it wasn't just below part
network connectivity either the game was
super buggy and glitched out all the
time but thankfully with consistent
updates from dice the game shaped up
quite nicely and with an incredible
amount of content thanks to dlc releases
like china rising naval strike dragon's
teeth and so much more battlefield 4
turned into a super fun game played to
this day
[Music]
battlefield hardline is a mainline
battlefield game but wasn't directly
developed by dice visceral games took
the helm for this entry and decided to
introduce a completely different spin on
the battlefield formula rather than
military warfare we got a game that
focused on crime and heists basically
glorified cops vs robbers the game
continued the trend of evolution and had
some really fantastic spectacles of its
own the revolution in battlefield 4 was
fantastic sure but i found the bank
vault crashing down or the construction
crane careening into nearby buildings to
be criminally underrated battlefield
hardline introduced completely new
multiplayer game modes players could
dive into games like heist where
criminals try to break into a
cash-filled vault or attempt to blow
open an armored truck and then escort
cash filled packages to extraction blood
money was a mode combining capture the
flag elements with tug of war where both
factions try to swoop cache from an open
crate in the center of the map and
return it to their armored truck while
players also had the option to steal
money from the opposing team truck
hotwire flipped the traditional conquest
mode of flag capture points instead
using cars that players would hotwire
and drive around driving above a certain
speed would bleed out the enemy team's
tickets similar to how controlling a
flag majority in conquest would there
were a few competitive modes too that
were narrowed down to 5v5 battles
rescuing crosshair both gave players
only one life but with interesting
setups in rescue swat officers would try
to rescue hostages whereas in crosshair
the criminals would be on the move
instead attempting to kill a player
controlled vip that was basically a
snitch and had defected to the cops
next time on hardline
that was awesome the campaign was
okay and had its own gimmicky novelty
episode of crime dramas where choices
changed outcomes and the gameplay if you
paused the game and then reopened it
later a hilariously campy previously on
hardline montage would occur catching
you up on your own exploits previously
on hardline a lot of backstabbing
corrupt cop drama went on in the
campaign there was also a section where
a korean gang was literally just bumping
k-pop blasting it from a boom box in the
warehouse i'm literally not even kidding
about that part you can even see one of
them dancing
[Music]
i'm sick of this song man sucks for you
seriously turn it down no way not till
song's over god it's gonna be a long
time
battlefield 1 took the fight back to the
first world war which is really notable
because it was at direct odds with call
of duty's infinite warfare's future
setting which no one wanted apparently
[Music]
it was a massive pr win for dice and
that battlefield 1 which was inspired by
historical events looked gritty and
grand and incredibly intriguing the
world war one backdrop added distinct
weapons like bolt action rifles smgs
auto and semi-auto rifles artillery
flame throwers and poison gas the
vehicles were plentiful with the buy and
triplane aircrafts being some of the
coolest in my experience in both
aesthetic and gameplay for those who
prefer tanks there are plenty of those
as well and light and heavy versions
in-game animations showing your
character moving around the vehicle to
swap positions kept immersion levels at
an all-time high most notably there was
the addition of cavalry units which were
honestly tanky in their own right those
horses could take several bullets if not
straight up tank shells before going
down giving you ample time to swing a
saber or shoot enemies with a long-range
rifle battlefield 1 ditched the standard
revolution introduced in battlefield 4
but added its own twist with the use of
behemoths which were a new gameplay
mechanic behemoths took on three forms
they appeared either as an armored train
dreadnought or zeppelin and were used as
a climactic form of support for the
losing side during a battle in
operations for example if a defending or
attacking team had their wave of
reinforcements wiped out a behemoth
would appear giving them a handicap for
their second wave of reinforcements
behemoths were incredibly powerful and
when destroyed particularly in the
zeppelins case took on the spectacle
that levolution used to offer in the
prior game the campaign wasn't one
cohesive story but a collection of
different accounts across different
countries and units the prologue in
particular was interesting and then as
soon as your character died you moved on
to another perspective simultaneously
putting names to the forgotten faces of
war while ironically having you
literally forget those names at the same
time as you moved between character
after character in the games you could
feel dice's symbolic nod to the
casualties of war the multiplayer maps
were awesome with plentiful locations
ranging from the western front to arabia
to the alps there were also new game
modes like war pigeons where players
would secure war pigeons and use them to
call artillery strikes operations were a
brand new mode and they were one of my
favorite battlefield modes of all time
there were super long war campaigns in
multiplayer that were similar to rush
but if the attackers captured all the
different sectors the battle would
continue onto a completely different
nearby map if you want to talk about
battlefield moments take some time to
appreciate the incredible adrenaline
rush felt when a sector was successfully
captured the transition towards the next
sector as characters in game just start
howling with planes and tanks whizzing
by on your way to the next arena but the
music swelling was nothing short of
magical just listen to this
battlefield 5 brought the fight back to
world war ii and continued the episodic
war stories instead of traditional
campaigns before we dive into some of
the other changes it is worth addressing
the elephant in the room battlefield
decided to commit to a level of realism
but got off to a shaky pr start as many
fans fixated on how unrealistic and
silly customization seemed to them while
there could be a legitimate criticism
around realism unfortunately it seems
that a subset of that group focused a
little too much on the game's inclusion
of women which seems to come from a
place of misogyny battlefield v had a
hard time shaking off this stigma and
the online internet memes and some fans
decided to boycott the game outright and
took their frustrations online the fact
remains that battlefield v although not
a smashing success wasn't nearly as
awful and horrible as many people
swearing in the comments section of the
trailer would want you to believe but
i'm also not saying that the game was
perfect the fact remains that all
battlefield games have room to improve
but i just wanted to square this away
with you guys so we can all move on
together because we have so much to be
excited about with battlefield 2042
later down the road behemoths and
levolution were gone in battlefield v
but destruction still played a heavy
role with players able to craft bunkers
and turrets with various kits to use the
maps were pretty varied with some
encouraging close quarters while other
maps represented real-life world war ii
battles such as panzerstorm a map that
had an incredible amount of tanks and
vehicles lastly there was a new battle
royale mode known as firestorm the name
represented the growing fire that took
the role of being the battle royal
mode's map boundary that progressively
began to shrink as the round continued
firestorm also featured the largest
battlefield map of all time palvoy and
the mode wasn't developed by dice
directly but by criterion games i don't
think firestorm ever took off in
popularity compared to the other modes
but i also don't know how much of that
is relative to people disliking
battlefield v as a whole for those of
you in the comments let me know if you
actually enjoyed firestorm
all right we're finally here we're
finally at the battlefield that we are
all hyped for we have plenty of really
good breakdowns on everything you need
to know about battlefield 2042 that are
super in depth but to hit the main
points battlefield 2042 brings us to a
near future setting in the game climate
change has reached its peak in
volatility and we're on route to
apocalyptic climate change now that's
all fine for the game setup but the
first thing you need to know is that
battlefield 2042 will have 128 player
servers for next-gen players which is is
just insanity to help mitigate the sheer
number of players battlefield 2042 will
have some of the biggest maps of all
time this means that conquest and flag
placements have been reworked into
clusters and sectors clusters are
specific areas of engagement designed
for players to group up and combat each
other over other flag points meanwhile
sectors are a larger group of different
clusters when all the flags are captured
then the sector in its entirety is
considered to be captured as well
specialists were introduced and are an
all-new type of fully voiced playable
soldier inspired by the traditional
battlefield classes specialists will be
equipped with individual unique traits
and a specialty with fully customizable
loadouts available there will be 10
specialists at launch with 4 planned and
upcoming seasons already revealed are
boris casper falk mckay and irish with
more details on the remaining
specialists coming later the specialties
and traits are unique and cannot be
changed for example falk is a combat
surgeon and has a trait that allows her
to revive allies to full health having
an advantage over squad revives which
take longer with not as much health
gained mckay on the other hand has a
grappling hook specialty allowing him to
quickly swing up to high ground each
squad will have four players maxed and
in conquest and breakthrough squads can
have more than one of the same
specialists 2042 will also have fully
customizable loadouts for all players
where you no longer have certain weapons
restricted based on class instead you
have access to all primary weapons
equipment such as medical crates or
anti-vehicle weapons a secondary weapon
and a throwable there's a new
tablet-based call-in system for allowing
you to call in everything from an apc to
a boston dynamics looking robodog known
as the ranger the system is based on an
allocation of team points and has a
cooldown timer there are also
environmental hazards such as emp storms
sandstorms and tornadoes all part of the
new dynamic weather system battlefield
2042 won't launch with naval warfare
according to a recent battlefield
briefing but in my mind there's room for
a potential there for dlc similar to
battlefield 4's naval strike expansion
and we already know there will be
remastered maps thanks to battlefield
portal the game will also not have an
offline mode but you can still hop in
and train with bots which are also
included in 128 player server madness
lastly battlefield 2042 has confirmed
cross-platform play being a work in
progress and that with cross-play comes
cross-progression and cross-commerce
meaning all of your purchases and
progress on one platform will carry over
on a central account allowing you to
access it all on a different platform
battlefield 2042 also introduced
battlefield portal which sounds like the
ultimate fan service and every
battlefield fans dream come true in
battlefield portal you have 6 remastered
maps across 1942 bad company 2 and
battlefield 3 making their return with a
fresh and updated visual quality the
maps allow players to fully customize a
massive list of options including
pitting armies from different eras
against one another choosing what
weapons and attachments they fight with
picking when conditions what vehicles
are available and even using a logic
editor to program modes like gun game or
protect the vip some of the modes that
players can make are really funny like
an eod bot versus tank scenario or wing
suits versus aircraft the destruction is
ramped up and is an added element to
some of the maps that might never have
had destruction on them before such as
battlefield 1942's el alamine they're
also updating maps to factor in the
larger lobbies of 2042 giving bad
company 2's valparaiso map a new low
tide area for instance to help create
more surface area for players favorite
weapons such as the tracer dart make
their return as well and with all of the
maps being developed onto the latest
edition of frostbite it is exciting to
see some of the most iconic sections of
battlefield's history fused together in
awesome combinations that exaggeration
it looks like one hell of a good time
battlefield has gone quite the distance
over the years and with all signs
pointing towards 2042 being an
action-packed hype vest i'm here for it
we've come such a long way from the
refractor engine days of battlefield
1942 and with all the lessons dice has
learned over the last two decades
hopefully battlefield 2042 will make a
significant mark in the series tell me
which battlefield game was your favorite
and why also let me know if you were a
fan of any of the smaller battlefield
games i skipped like battlefield heroes
or play for free and let me know why you
hate yourself so much if those games are
your favorite be sure to stick around
this season as we get a lot more
battlefield content coming your way
especially taking a look at the new
hazard zone it's been a blast making
these videos and it wouldn't have
happened if it wasn't for all the
excitement coming from you all in the
comments and on my twitter feed so a big
thank you i'm excited to whip up some
more videos for you guys in the future
so make sure you stick to gamespot until
next time
[Music]
you